where
in modern life can we be accepted by
others in all of our facets
the beautiful and the ugly the
comfortable and the uncomfortable
how do we open that pandora's box
and dance with it
my name is evangeline and i am a puto
artist
bhuto is an art form that was born in
japan in the 1950s now it is a global
art form
for me butu is the dance of darkness the
dance of the subconscious
i think that body and mind and spirit
are completely connected
when we access the body through
repetition there is a part of the mind
that surrenders and we begin to access
emotions
there is no homo erectus anymore
but training is really really really
challenging to be pushed to the limit to
that extent and encouraged to have an
encounter with yourself is not an easy
endeavor
but it's a particularly acute challenge
for people who are incarcerated
i started my work in correctional
facilities with bhutto in 2006.
yeah nice
the classes at hcom are very powerful
they're also a process
and in the correctional facilities it's
a very volatile environment
my agenda is to start from a blank slate
it's not my place to judge them it's my
place to provide a space of self
acceptance for them a place for
rehabilitation
once they connect to the sense of
empowerment that's a very important
concept for people who are incarcerated
self-knowledge self-power
how can i be in control of my of my body
that is essentially being controlled by
the state
the ones that keep coming back and
repeat and believe in the repetition and
start on a path of commitment achieve
great results
it's a dance from the guts it's a dance
from the soul
it's magic
you